there is no good reason why the opinions
and proclamations of the world
professional association for transgender
health or wpath should matter at all to
anyone the organization was founded in
the late 1970s not by a medical doctor
but by a social a social psychologist
named Paul Allen Walker Walker worked
with John money who as you know if you
heard on this show is the depraved quack
who performed sexual experiments on
young boys causing two of his test
subjects to kill themselves uh Walker
for his part who was openly gay lived in
the Castro District in San Francisco set
up his practice in the same city where
he helped facilitate sex change
surgeries back like in the 60s and 70s
he also had a treatment center quote
unquote for sex offenders but Walker
never met someone who wouldn't be
diagnosed with gender dysphoria
according to him I mean he would just
diagnose anyone for example Walt heyer
who's a man who D transitioned back in
the early 90s and has been speaking out
against the gender ideology industry
ever since he tells the story of his
initial consultations with Walker in
1981 now higher
was abused by his grandmother as a very
young boy if you've heard his story
before you're familiar with it but he
was just to summarize very briefly he
was forced to dress in girl clothing as
like a four-year-old Child by his by his
grandmother
and to use the current phrase in other
words he was sort of socially
transitioned into a girl against his
will just because his grandmother was a
an abusive
psychopath now in his 40s higher became
a patient of Walker and explained this
history of childhood abuse and Trauma to
him but he was immediately diagnosed
with gender dysphoria anyway and
recommended for hormones and surgery so
to be clear Walker's recommendation was
that higher should use drugs and surgery
to affirm the false identity that his
insane abuse of Grandmother created for
him when he was four years old that's
the kind of mental health professional
that Walker the founder of wpath was
eventually he died of AIDS and the
leadership of wpath was passed on to
somebody else which brings us to
today today the president of the
organization is a man named Walter
Pierre Bowman who is a sexologist and
quote unquote trans health specialist
he's on his way out though apparently
and the president-elect of the
organization is Marcy Bowers who's the
trans uh sex change surgeon featured in
my film what is a woman
the organization's Treasurer is a guy
named Lauren Schechter who's a plastic
surgeon from Chicago and who also
performs gender transitions on adults
and children in fact all the way down
the line from president on down
in this organization you find people who
are not only totally ideologically
invested in the trans agenda
and therefore untrustworthy sources of
information
but even worse they are financially
invested
Bowers Schechter many of the rest in
leadership and on the board all have
made millions of dollars from the gender
affirmation business
so now they're in charge of wpath and
the more that wpath relaxes their
recommendations and guidelines and sort
of opens things up and the more of the
population that they can include as
potential patients and as potential
candidates for uh gender affirmation
procedures quote unquote the more money
they personally make
this is a conflict of interest to say
the least
and yet it has not stopped wpath from
becoming the leading Authority on trans
Health in the world
not according to me anyway but according
to uh all the you know major medical
institutions and organizations
it shouldn't matter what they say or
what they recommend but it does because
whatever they declare
is uncritically adopted by every other
major medical organization in the
Western World which is what makes their
highly anticipated set of new guidelines
just released this week unfortunately
relevant
Christina buttons who's our new and
quite Fearless reporter at the daily
wire reports this
quote um the the leading transgender
Health Association has released its much
anticipated new guidelines one aspect
noticeably different from previous
editions is that the explicitly stated
minimal age recommendations for minors
to have to obtain puberty blockers
crossed sex hormones and surgeries have
been removed
now to uh State the obvious year or to
restate
that means that there is now no official
minimum age recommendation for any
gender transition procedure
so continuing the new guidance also
suggests that if parents do not affirm
their child's newly chosen identity the
state may be unable to intervene in
order to assist with the child's
transition
wpath published its standards of care
8th Edition in the international Journal
transgender Health on September 6 2022 a
correction was published in the same
journal on September 15th which removed
sections pertaining to quote minimal
ages for gender affirming medical and
surgical treatments for adolescents a
confidential draft of the eighth edition
was released for public review in
December 2021 that lowered the
recommended minimum age for minors to
obtain cross-sex hormones which cause
permanent changes to the body from 16 to
14 and then also irreversible chest face
and general surgeries to 15 16 and 17
respectively little has changed from the
early draft and while wpath no longer
provides explicit minimum age
recommendations in their latest Official
Guidelines a close reading of the text
finds that age suggestions are woven
into the text so
before I read a little bit more of this
there are basically two ways to
potentially interpret
wpath's decision to remove the explicit
minimum age recommendations from the
text one is that they don't want there
to be any minimum age you know they want
to open the door for any procedure at
any age we heard from a gender surgeon
in a clip last week
that he doesn't recognize any minimum
age at all for any form of medical
intervention we heard that explicitly
or you might theorize the wpath removed
some of these minimum age guidelines or
at least made them harder to find in the
text made them a little bit less clear
because they don't want people to know
that these things are being done to kids
as young as 14.
I mean they've been talking openly about
doing these things to kids for many
years but now some of us are paying
attention and drawing attention to it
and they don't want that
which is the same reason why children's
hospitals and other clinics around the
country have been frantically removing
this information from their website any
mention of performing any sort of
procedures on kids that are moving with
the website not because they don't do it
anymore but because they don't want us
to notice it they don't want to give us
something really simple that we can
point to and say oh you see
they're trying to make it harder to for
critics to expose what's going on rather
than laying it all out plainly in a
document that we can again just point to
and say well there it is now I tend to
think that out of these two possible
explanations maybe there's truth to both
read it gone uh chapter 6 on Adolescence
in the new guideline suggests that
cross-sex hormones may be administered
to children as young as 14.
quoting from the document it says more
recent guidelines suggest there may be
compelling reasons to initiate gender
affirming hormone therapy prior to the
age of 16. although there are limited
studies on youth who have initiated
hormones prior to 14 years of age
in the same chapter so you see how they
they have the ages there they make it a
little bit more obscure what they're
actually saying a little bit more
in the same chapter guidance is issued
for chest masculinization surgery
otherwise known as a double mastectomy
which is the removal of healthy breasts
quoting again for the document it says
chest masculinization surgery can be
considered in minors when clinically and
developmentally appropriate as
determined by a multi-disciplinary team
experienced in Adolescent and gender
development though no precise age is
indicated most pediatric gender clinics
will perform double mastectomy surgeries
on uh 15 year olds guidance on
vaginoplasty is the creation of a
pseudo-vagina using existing genital
tissue indicates that they may be
obtained as a minor as well quoting
again from the document while the sample
sizes are small these studies suggest
there may be a benefit for some
adolescents to having these procedures
performed before the age of 18 reads the
guidelines
now
keep in mind again
that younger children
undergoing gender transition means
millions of more dollars in the pockets
of the very people who are making these
recommendations
now we should know that wpath does at
least have one form of genital
mutilation which it uh does not yet
recommend for kids quote the only
General Surgery it seems the wpath is
comfortable setting an age
recommendation for is phalloplasty which
creates a penis-like phallus from skin
grafts taken elsewhere in the body
they the document says given the
complexity of phalloplasty and current
High rates of complications in
comparison to other gender affirming
surgical treatments it is not
recommended that this surgery be
considered in youth under 18 at this
time
the at this time qualifier is rather
glaring and conspicuous
and so is this part
reading from the document
we recommend when gender affirming
medical or surgical treatments are
indicated for adolescents Healthcare
professionals working with transgender
and gender diverse adolescents involve
parents or Guardians in the assessment
and treatment process unless their
involvement is determined to be harmful
to the Adolescent or not feasible
helping Youth and parents caregivers
work together on important gender care
decisions is a primary goal however in
some cases parents and caregivers may be
too rejecting of their adolescent child
and their child's gender needs to be
part of the clinical evaluation process
in these situations youth may require
the engagement of larger systems of
advocacy and support to move forward
with the necessary support and care
um
now this statement
from wpath will be and has been reported
as wpath recommending parental consent
other being responsible they're saying
that there should be printables in
but they're actually doing the opposite
which is quite obvious when you read it
what they're saying is that parental
consent matters
if the parent says yes
if the parent says no their opinion
doesn't matter
so you only get consent if the consent
if there is consent consent only matters
if you say yes
which is to say that your consent
doesn't matter your opinion doesn't
matter at all in either case
the medical establishment is saying to
the parents here we're going to do what
we want to your kids and we'll get the
state involved if we have to
and uh you can give us your approval and
we'll do it or you can disapprove and
we'll still do it
what this means is that the approval is
irrelevant and symbolic at best
the parents are cut out of the equation
and consent is deferred not to the child
who cannot actually consent
but to the very surgeons and doctors who
are financially invested in
transitioning as many people as they can
as young as they can
and as fast as they can
that's what so much of this is about
now we know that they are
um rabid ideologues that are in the
gender transition industry and they're
at wpath and their
as I said ideologically invested in this
um their their religious Fanatics and
they want to induct as many people as
they can into their cult and that's
what's driving a lot of it
but we can't Overlook the fact that
they're also just scam artists
trying to make a buck or two or two
billion
[Music]
that's what much of this traces back to
I know you're craving some more Matt
Walsh show content while I have some
great news for you if you head over to
dailywire.com And subscribe now you can
watch or listen to my full show you can
also listen to my podcast on Spotify
Apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcast I'll see you there